[MUSIC PLAYING]
MODERATOR: I am pleased to
welcome to the platform William
J. Clinton, President
of the United States;
Dr. David D. Ho, graduate of the
Harvard MIT division of Health
Science and Technology,
professor at Rockefeller
University, scientific director
and chief executive officer
of the Aaron Diamond
AIDS Research Center
and 1996 Time magazine
Man of the Year;
and the Honorable
Francis J. Duehay, mayor
of the city of Cambridge.
Dr. Ho will now
give his address.
[APPLAUSE]
HO: Thank you.
It's great to be back.
Good morning, President Clinton,
Mayor Duehay, President Vest,
Mr. D'Arbeloff, members of the
MIT Corporation and faculty.
To the graduates and their
families and friends,
my heartfelt congratulations--
it is indeed a momentous
day in your lives.
What an incredible honor it
is for me to return to MIT
as a commencement speaker.
As a young immigrant boy growing
up in Southern California,
I was awed by this august
institution from afar.
My love for science was
inspired by the genius
of extraordinary men like
Feynmann, Luria, Baltimore,
and Ting, whose presence,
at one time or another,
graced this campus.
Later, it was within the
Harvard MIT Health Sciences
and Technology program where
my clinical skills were honed,
where my scientific
interests were solidified,
and where I truly learned
to tackle research
with a multi-disciplinary
approach, not
limited by arbitrary
boundaries that
separate biomedical sciences
from physics, chemistry,
engineering, and mathematics.
I will forever be
indebted to you.
I'm here today because I've been
given a great deal of praise
and recognition for recent
advances made in AIDS research.
Achievements in research seldom
belong to a single individual.
Science is a richly
collaborative endeavor
and my personal recognition
is merely symbolic
for the many
important discoveries
and contributions made by a
cadre of talented scientists
in the field.
As Newton aptly put it in
a letter to Robert Hook,
"If I had seen further,
it is by standing
upon the shoulder of giants."
The recent media attention
focused on age research
has provided a
unique opportunity
to educate the public
at large about a plague
of staggering dimensions and
to advocate to our leader
a proper course of action.
It is also gratifying
to see that the media is
willing, on occasions,
to prominently feature
scientists with accomplishments
that move our society forward.
However, on a personal
note, I find the spotlight
is hot enough to bake.
And as scientists-- as
Einstein had cautioned,
"The only way to avoid
the corruption of praise
is to keep on working."
I feel extremely
privileged to work on AIDS.
As a young physician
in Los Angeles in 1981,
I was fortunate
enough to witness
the beginning of the visible
part of the epidemic.
Over the course of a year,
young men, one after another,
presented to the hospital with
a multitude of infections,
leading to death
within days to weeks.
It was evident that their
immune system was damaged.
But by what?
Their medical history strongly
suggested the possibility
of a sexually transmitted agent
that caused immunodeficiency.
And yet, any description
of a similar syndrome
was nowhere to be found
in the medical literature.
The disease was obviously new.
In this manner, AIDS appeared
insidiously and mystified
doctors and scientists alike.
No one could have predicted
that 17 years later we
would face a global
epidemic of HIV infection
that is arguably the
plague of the Millennium.
Today, HIV continues to
spread at an alarming rate
of 16,000 new cases per day.
And more than 50
million infections
are expected by the year 2000.
For a biomedical scientist,
what could represent a greater
opportunity than
to conduct research
on a lethal microbe
that threatens
the health of the entire world?
Members of the class of
'98, as you move on in life,
be prepared to take advantage
of the opportunities that
have bubbled up by serendipity.
Then have the courage
and conviction
in pursuing your
goals and ideals.
In science and engineering, you
have chosen noble professions,
ones filled with excitement.
Nothing is more thrilling
to me than the process
of scientific discovery.
When the wonder of
nature is revealed,
one is left breathless
and awestruck.
Imagine the joy and
intellectual satisfaction
when the constant expansion
of our vast universe
was discovered, when the complex
nature of the chemical bond
was understood, or when the
double helical structure of DNA
was solved.
Imagine the excitement that must
have pervaded this campus when
the synthesis of DNA was
achieved from an RNA template.
Imagine, as well, the
fruits of science,
the sense of accomplishment
in those engineers
when an electrical current was
transformed into light, when
sound waves were transmitted
across long distances
in a wire, or when
a cushion of air
was harvested to send
men soaring into the sky.
Allow me a more modest,
but personal, anecdote.
Beginning in '91,
my colleagues and I
had the privilege of working
with structural biologists
and medicinal chemists to
test small chemicals that
might intercalate into the
catalytic site of the HIV
protease, an enzyme
essential for the production
of infectious progeny virus.
So overwhelming
was the excitement
that overtook us when substances
were found to potently inhibit
this enzyme, thereby blocking
viral replication in the test
tube.
Three years later, we
again had the privilege
of being the first to administer
one of these chemicals
to infected patients.
Unmatched were the
joy and amazement
as we watched the level of
HIV fall ever so dramatically.
At first, little
did we know that we
were sitting on top of a
fundamental discovery in AIDS
research.
But shortly
thereafter, by simply
asking why does the virus
fall, and why does it
fall in that manner,
it quickly dawned on us
that HIV must be
turning over rapidly
in a very dynamic
equilibrium with a host.
Using data from patients,
working with mathematicians,
we proved HIV replication
in the patient
was rapid and remorseless.
In the course of
only a few weeks,
the old paradigm that HIV
was largely a latent virus
was completely shattered.
So incredible was the ensuing
intellectual satisfaction
that I now fully appreciate
the meaning of a line
in a book, The Ascendant Man.
It reads, "When the
answers are simple,
then you hear God thinking."
Despite the breakneck speed
of scientific discovery
in the field, AIDS
patients already
faced a decade and a half of
horror and disappointment.
But because of
science there is hope.
In the past two years, with
new knowledge and new therapy,
it has become possible
to control HIV
so effectively that
the virus is no
longer detectable in
the infected person.
This dramatic
attack is associated
with a substantial clinical
benefit to the patient.
For the first time in
this dreadful epidemic,
the tide has begun to
turn against the virus.
Although a cure is
still not in hand,
as stated in Time
magazine, the worst fear,
the one that seeded a
decade with this fear,
the foreboding sense that the
AIDS virus might be invincible
has finally been subdued.
After years of cursing
the darkness of AIDS,
a candle of hope has
been lit by science.
AIDS, however, is not over.
Worldwide, most infected persons
cannot access the promising new
therapies and much remains to be
done in controlling the spread
of this epidemic.
It is my deepest hope that the
recent scientific advances will
inspire government, academia,
and the private sector
to remain vigilant and to
redouble our efforts to bring
an end to this tragedy.
Prevention is the ultimate
key to controlling
the epidemic and vaccine science
must now take center stage,
as was declared by
President Clinton last year.
Recently my thoughts
had taken me
on a number of
self-reflective journeys.
Let me humbly share a
few with the graduates.
In our experiments
attempting to eliminate HIV
from an infected
person, I've learned
that success in research, as
is the case in most endeavors,
requires bold decision
making and a willingness
to take informed risks.
As so eloquently stated by
Harrow Shapiro of Princeton,
"An excessive zeal to avoid
all risks is, in the end,
an acceptance of mediocrity and
an abdication of leadership."
Graduates, you must take
on the toughest challenge,
but view it as the
greatest opportunity.
For every noble work is, at
first, seemingly impossible.
Heed the wise words
of Teddy Roosevelt
before the turn of the
century, "Far better it
is to dare mighty things, to
win glorious triumphs even
though checkered by
failure, than to rank
with those poor spirits who
neither enjoy nor suffer much,
because they live in the
great twilight that knows
neither victory nor defeat."
More and more I've also
reflected on the role
of science in our society.
I'm disturbed by the
public's indifference
to what we do as
scientists and engineers.
As children, we all began
with a real zest for science.
We were curious and provocative,
and insightful questions
blurted out constantly.
However, by early adulthood,
this proclivity to science
and the joy of
discovery have somehow
dissipated in most, only to
be replaced by science phobia.
Consequently, it
is not surprising
that our society has often
stereotyped, unflatteringly,
those scientists and
engineers who carry out
incomprehensible lines of work.
Edison, Bell, and
the Wright brothers
would be today's nerds,
even though the products
of their ingenuity have
made our world better.
I'm particularly
saddened by the fact
that many of my personal
heroes in science
are virtual unknowns
to a typical citizen.
While certain dubious
characters are universally
recognized and often
glorified by our society.
As scientists and engineers,
we must change this
by learning to present our
work in both interesting and
understandable ways.
Indeed, it is our
responsibility to bring back
that spark, the sense
of wonder about nature,
that lies within every citizen.
I'm equally troubled by this
society's lack of commitment
to research in basic science.
A former president said
in a campaign speech,
why should we subsidize
intellectual curiosity?
The simple, but
naive question speaks
volumes of the lack
of appreciation
of the richness that uninhibited
fundamental research has
brought us.
Carl Sagan said it best when he
wrote, "Maxwell wasn't thinking
of radio, radar, and television
when he first scratched out
the fundamental equations
of electromagnetism.
Newton wasn't dreaming of
space flights or communications
satellites when he
first understood
the motion of the moon.
Roentgen wasn't contemplating
medical diagnosis
when he investigated a
penetrating radiation so
mysterious he called it x-rays.
Curie wasn't thinking
of cancer therapy
when she painstakingly extracted
minute amounts of radium
from tons of pitchblende.
Fleming wasn't planning on
saving lives of millions
with antibiotics when he noticed
a circle free of bacteria
around a growth of mold.
Watson and Crick
weren't imagining
the cure of genetic
diseases when
they puzzled over the X-ray
diffraction pattern of DNA."
These discoveries
and a multitude
of others that graced
and characterized
our time were made,
ultimately, by scientists given
the opportunity to explore
what in their opinions
were basic questions and nature.
Cutting off fundamental,
curiosity driven science
is like eating the seed corn.
George Washington
said in 1790, "there
is nothing which can better
deserve our patronage
than the promotion of science.
Knowledge is, in every
country, the surest basis
of public happiness."
Graduates, in the
best tradition of MIT,
always maintain unwaveringly a
deep commitment to excellence.
As you enter a career in
science or engineering,
stay in the forefront
of your chosen field,
and never permit the excellence
of your work to be compromised.
Believe in what you are doing.
As Max Planck said,
"Over the entrance
of the gates to the temple of
science are written the words,
ye must have faith.
It is a quality which the
scientists cannot dispense
with."
I remember with a
great deal of fondness
my mates from the class of '74.
Just like you, what
a bunch they were.
Stay young at heart, but
should you need to grow,
do not suppress
your individuality
and insist on conformity.
"Continue to let
imagination and creativity
percolate throughout your
lives, for every great advance
in science has issued from the
new audacity of imagination,"
said John Dewey.
I also reflected on the
contribution of my heritage
to my career.
Were it not for the
profound Asian respect
for intellectual achievements
and scholarly endeavors,
a scientist I
might not be today.
Moreover, values of
drive, dedication,
imprinted during
early childhood have
continued to serve me well.
In any culture, there's simply
no substitute for hard work.
I've been an
American for so long
that I often forget that
I'm also an immigrant.
From time to time, I could
still sense the desire
that burns in the belly of
a new immigrant, the desire
to carve out a place
in the new world,
in the land of opportunities.
To this day, I maintain
an underdog mentality
that motivates me to a
higher level of work ethics.
Let me begin to
close with a comment.
Throughout its
history, Americans
continue to benefit from the
drive labor and creativity
of immigrants, many in the field
of science and engineering.
Just look among the
graduates this morning.
Thus, today, one prevailing
view that immigrants constitute
a constant drain on our society
is simply baseless, wrong,
and shameful, particularly
in this nation of immigrants.
[APPLAUSE]
Graduates, as future
scientists and engineers,
it is likely that you
will, on occasions,
be underappreciated,
under recognized,
and more likely,
underpaid by our society.
[LAUGHTER]
You will have to take
solace and satisfaction
in knowing that
your work has helped
to build a better, safer,
healthier, and richer world,
a world with hope.
Members of the class
of '98, it matters
not whether you work on numbers,
atoms, molecules, machines,
organisms, the
Earth, or the cosmos.
Through science and
technology, any one of you
can cast a giant
shadow on our planet.
Congratulations, and don't
forget to thank your parents.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]